well I'm David Arquette and i'm here on
the set of jeff 1000 working with the
robot is different it's like you have to
wait to say your line till he like me
eat me you have to make sure he computes
I mean leave his operating system isn't
probably the fastest he needs like a 5g
upgrade it's pretty tricky you got to
watch him you never know like we're
gonna turn on you know green M&M snow
green mi names I think to be honest you
know not to take the whole production or
anything but Wally's too big for this
this is just something for the internet
I don't know what to think about the
Jeff and summer relationship I mean I'm
open-minded anyone should be able to
date anyone they want but I don't know
it's scary when you think about what
happens there I don't know what Jeff
thinks about when he's acting when you
stare into his eyes I can't really even
find his eyes but they're blank uh yeah
I guess he's great John I don't know
what the obsession with death is really
um Jeff can't have here so his hair
would probably look like wires well
what's your obsession with Jeff oh I
mean no I'd come back as me I wouldn't
want to come back as a robot that's
completely ridiculous what would you
tell me well I'm sure it's gonna be
another question about Jeff to be honest
with you bro I'm boiling and this is
like my break time so I'm gonna go to
craft service where Jeff won't be
because he can't eat
you